Okay, get ready.
Here is the question.
What is the most important lesson you've learned in your life...
..and how would you apply it to your time as Miss Universe?
I work a lot in the slums of Tondo, Manila,...
...and the life there is very, it's poor and it's very sad,...
...and I've always taught myself to look for the beauty in it,...
...to look in the beauty in the faces of the children, and to be grateful,...
...and I would bring this aspect as a Miss Universe...
...to see situations with a silver lining and to assess...
...where I could give something,...
...where I could provide something as a spokesperson,...
...and this, I think, if I could teach also people to be grateful,...
...we could have an amazing world where negativity could not grow and foster,...
...and children would have a smile on their face.
Thank you.
Thank you, Philippines.